In the real world what you see is usually what you get
this cone
this cylinder
and this stuffed horse are all inanimate objects
But what if you could unleash some childhood fantasies
and make them move on their own?
New research out of Yale University can make that a reality
Pliable robotic skins can be wrapped around soft bodied objects
giving them the ability to bend, creep, even trot along
Like a blood-pressure cuff the skin covers the object with an elastic or fabric material
over tiny pressurized strips of electronic actuators, or more simply, air valves
But while a blood pressure cuff squeezes with the same force in all directions
the robotic skin pushes at different speeds in different places
These pushes give this frame and canvas ball
or your favorite childhood toy
the ability to walk, wobble, even roll
Researchers didn't stop at using these skins to simply move objects
They outfitted one cylinder with a camera and adjusted its skin so it can crawl along like an inchworm
such worm-bots can be used in rescue operations and for exploring tiny spaces
that humans are just too big to enter
the robotic skins on this person's back can detect bad posture and alert them
The possibilities are endless, but that's kind of the point
Researchers have high hopes of using this handy technology
in places where one object might need to do the task of many
like outer space
Currently it costs millions to send payloads to Mars and the International Space Station
If robotic skins can help repurpose out-of-date tools, they could save space programs a bundle
Meanwhile, it never hurts to dream